bonjour Olivier fort merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique député
Tiem premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de Ouest
France Bonjour Stéphane bonjour bonjour
bonjour on va évidemment parler de la
situation en Israël Olivier fort et
d'abord ce qui se passe sur place
benjamine nthaniaou qui promet une
attaque massivere contre le Hamas d'une
intensité qui n'a jamais eu lieu c'est
ce qu'il a dit laissant présager une
vive escalade de violence pouvait-il en
être autrement bon d'abord je veux
rappeler quand même ce qui s'est passé
et que quand le
ramas tue massacre femme enfant
vieillard qu'elle le fait sans
discernement aucun attaque des
populations civiles ça n'est pas un acte
de résistance c'est du terrorisme et
donc ça mérite une condamnation
universelle maintenant la réponse que
doit apporter l'État d'Israël doit être
aussi proportionnée et je crains
effectivement ce que vous dites vous
appelez vous-même une escalade de la
violence qui conduis en réalité non pas
à ce que la paix soit rétablie mais
est-ce qu'il y a un engrenage impossible
qui conduise en réalité à la
prolongation de ce qu' conflit qui a
déjà beaucoup trop duré et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous appelons
depuis toujours et j'espère que dans un
temps qui doit être le plus proche
possible de nous pourront être relancés
des pourparl qui permettent de trouver
un chemin pour une paix durable et la
solution pour les socialistes c'est une
solution à deux états un État
palestinien qui s'autodétermine en même
temps un état israélien qui est garanti
dans sa sécurité qui serait aujourd'hui
en mesure de de d'imposer un C c'est le
fait augirant et de de de rouvrir les
négociations que vous appelez vu la vu
l'état de la situation je ne sais pas
qui éit capable de l'imposer mais la
raison devrait l'imposer parce que la
réalité c'est que on sait très bien que
même si ce que je viens de dire je ne
reviens pas dessus mais c'est tout à
fait condamnable et le terrorisme n'est
pas supportable mais la réalité c'est
qu'il se nourrit aussi de la situation
dans laquelle vivent les Palestiniens
aujourd'hui dans les territoires occupés
et dans dans la bande de mais est-ce que
quand vous êtes attaqué d'une telle
façon vous êtes prêt à négocier la P
est-ce que la ripost n'est pas
inéluctable il y a aujourd'hui un
traumatisme dans la population
israélienne qui est tout à fait
compréhensible imaginez euh ce qu'il
qu'on subisse la même chose en France et
imaginez quelle serait la réaction du
peuple français donc c'est logique qu'
une réaction qui soit une
réaction qui qui s'apparente à une forme
de Rost mais peut-être même à une forme
de vengeance un peu aveugle et quand je
vois les images qui sont derrière vous
avec les bombardements qui attaquent en
qui euh qui bombarde le son discernement
population civile et évidemment
terroriste du ramas il y a des questions
à se poser vous avez écrit hier que le
Hamas avait jeté un avait tendu un piège
oui absolument au gouvernement israélien
qui s'est jeté tête baissée en étant
dans la dans la surenchère ou dans
l'escalade de de de violence en en en en
ripos mais comment comment est-ce qu'on
peut négocier quoi que ce soit avec un
groupe terroriste qui a pour seul projet
d'anéantir Israël et de et de tuer tous
les Juifs bah vous avez raison de
rappeler ce qu'est leur hamasse parce
que c'est une organisation terroriste et
c'est pour ça que ce n'est pas une c'est
pas une résistance palestinienne et
d'ailleurs il ne représente pas les
Palestiniens et donc la difficulté c'est
d'avoir effectivement une organisation
qui a toujours pour objectif non pas la
paix mais qui a pour objectif la
destruction de d'Israël et c'est la
raison pour laquelle évidemment les
combattre est nécessaire la réalité ceci
dit c'est que quand vous voulez négocier
à un moment il faut négocier avec
quelqu'un et je ne sais pas pas si c'est
avec le ramas qu'il faudra le faire et
c'est certainement l'Autorité
palestinienne qui devrait être
l'inlocuteur principal mais c'est une
autorité qui est très affaiblie
aujourd'hui et donc mais il faudra
trouver des interlocuteurs et je me
souviens que en son temps l'OLP avait
les mêmes objectifs que le ramas et que
Yasser Arafat avait été malgré tout un
faiseur de paix un peacemaker avec itsac
Rabine avec Shimon Perez et
malheureusement ces gens-là ont disparu
et avec eux la perspective de paix a
disparu et R nous rendez-vous compte que
depuis 95 on vit une situation qui est
insupportable avec cette idée que on
doit fermer les yeux qu'on regarde pas
ce qui se passe et que finalement et
bien la maîtrise du peuple palestinien
permet de continuer à avancer sans voilà
sans se préoccuper de ce qui se passera
la réalité c'est que malheureusement il
n'y a pas de paix durable sans justice
et en l'occurrence la justice suppose
deux états tant qu'il n'y aura pas la la
perspective d'un état PAL palestinien la
perspective pour le peuple palestinien
de s'autodéterminer la réalité c'est on
la sait c'est que malheureusement il y
aura de nouveaux drame et cette
génération qui est partie en ULM frapper
Israël c'est la génération qui est née
avec la première Intifada et donc il ne
faut pas croire que de maintenir une
population en état de survie est la
meilleure façon de s'assurer une paix
durable il y a le cas d'oré annoncé hier
soir la mort de deux Français dans ces
attaques il y a une quinzaine d'autres
français qui sont portés disparus est-ce
que vous demandez au gouvernement de
permettre le rapatriment des Français
d'Israël oui bien sûr et Air France de
reprendre ses liaison bah écoutez s'il
faut rapatrier il faut des liaisons ça
me paraît assez logique parce que pour
le moment ellisabeth borne l' exclu
dimanche elle disait c'est pas encore le
temps du rapatriment écoutez s'il y a
des gens qui souhaitent être rapatriés
il faut leur permettre de l'êtref
imaginer cette situation et imaginer ces
familles qui ont peut-être besoin soit
de sécuriser soit même de venir rassurer
celles et ceux quis attendent en France
donc je pense que il y a un moment où il
faut effectivement entendre la voix de
celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui sont dans
le traumatisme et c'est un traumatisme
violent Stéphane on va parler de la
marche qui avait lieu hier not vous avez
participé vous avez participé à la
marche de de solidarité en soutien à
Israël et contre le terrorisme hier hier
soir on vous a vu en tête de corortège
avec de très nombreuses autres
personnalités politiques est-ce que vous
avez pu échanger avec des participants
et que si oui que vous ont-ils dit bon
il y avait tout il y avait des gens qui
sont venus me
remercier qui me disaient que ils
étaient heureux de voir que le PS était
présent dans cette manifestation de
solidarité avec le peuple israélien qui
est aujourd'hui victime et il y en a
d'autres qui venaent me dire que il ne
comprenaient pas que je sois dans la
nupes et qu'il y ait en fait des gens
qui aent des position très différentes
au sein de cette alliance de cette
coalition je aurait répondu que ma place
était au cœur de la gauche et que une
coalition ça n'est pas en fait un bloc
unique il n'y a pas de chef de laanupes
il n'y a pas une position qui sera
déterminée par Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour
l'ensemble de la gauche LFI n'est pas
laanupes et aujourd'hui la réalité c'est
que LFI plus exactement la position
prise par la direction de de LFI est
minoritaire au sein de l'anupes puisque
vous avez le PC les vers le PS une
partie des insommis qui ont
qui se sont désolidarisé et qui ont au
contraire expliqué que on ne pouvait à
aucun moment justifier un acte
terroriste même si on peut comprendre ce
qui a nourri le geste de ceux qui ont
enfin de ceux qui ont accompli ces actes
terroriste mais la réalité c'est que
personne ne peut accepter ni même
atténuer la responsabilité du Hamas et
considérer que ce serait résist est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui une ligne rouge a été
franchie par la France insoumise mais je
sais pas si c'est une question de ligne
rouge c'est que effectivement moi je ne
je ne partage pas ce point de vue il y a
un désaccord qui est avec des accords
sur la table qui est évident et et je
souhaite que nous puissions rediscuter
de ces éléments et que qu' ait en fait
maintenant une évolution de la part de
l'fi j'observe d'ailleurs que sous la
pression hier manuel bonpard a accepté
de faire évoluer sa position il était
hier chez vos confrères de de de France
2 où il a pour la première fois condamné
le ramasse expliquer que dit sa
compassion avec le peuple israélien et
les victimes du terrorisme P ça vous
suffit ou est-ce que vous demandez plus
je demande je demande à ce qu'on puisse
avancer et que on puisse sur cette
question qui est une question très
difficile qui est une question très
sensible y compris en France y compris
d'ailleurs dans tous les pays du monde
parce que le conflit malheureusement
israëlpalestinien s'est exporté à
travers la planète et bien je pense que
sur une question aussi sensible que
celle-là il faut avoir une parole so une
parole de raison ne pas épouser les
thèses des uns ou des autres mais être
comme le dit parfois Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pour le coup non aligné et être de ceux
qui portent une parole qui est une
parole de justice une parole de paix une
parole qui permet d'éviter que se
fracture à la fois le monde arabe avec
le avec les pays occidentaux qu'on est à
nouveau en fait des mouvements qui à
travers le monde pulule et fasse
craindre à nouveau le P mais c'est pas
un petit désaccord Olivier for c'est pas
un petit sujet est-ce que vous pouvez
encore être allié avec la France
insoumise aujourd'hui mais poser la
question à Pedro Sanchez qui lui est
avec la coalition de la gauche radicale
de soumar qui est l'équivalent si vous
voulez de la France insoumise en France
il gouverne ensemble et les positions de
soumar sont exactement les mêmes que
celles de la France insoumise vous avez
à gauche depuis toujours des dissensions
qui sont très fortes notamment sur la
question israë palestin ça ve dire qu'il
faut tout accepter pour préserver
l'Union ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
tout accepter je n'accepte pas je vous
le dis à l'instant j'ai une position qui
est ferme qui est claire et qui ne
suppose pas la moindre atténuation de ma
part simplement je vous dis une chose
c'est que parfois l'Union est un combat
parfois effectivement il faut faire
respecter une parole et moi ce que je
veux faire aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
mal'aligner sur une position qui ne
serait pas la mienne c'est de faire en
sorte que toute la gauche rejoignent une
position qui est une position de raison
et de responsabilité le terrorisme n'est
à aucun moment acceptable et en même
temps puisqu'il en faut un cette fois-ci
et bien en même temps il faut aussi ne
pas épouser pour autant la cause du
gouvernement qui n'a jamais été aussi à
droite et aussi même à l'extrême droite
qu le gouvernement de netanahou et moi
je ne souhaite pas que nous puissions
considérer que la solidarité que le
peuple israélien soit un blancin pour le
gouvernement netaniaou qui est un
gouvernement qui à bien des égards est
aussi complice du ramas parce que la
réalité c'est que il y a en fait une
complicité objective entre les uns et
les autres entre ceux qui Contin
continuent à occuper à annexer et celles
et ceux qui de l'autre côté cherchent à
éradiquer les les les Juifs de d'Israël
il y a cette volonté chacun se nourrit
de son adversaire on comprend votre
position Olivier fort est-ce que vous
avez discuté avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
est-ce que vous lui demandez des
explications mais je l'ai déjà dit
publiquement non je n'ai pas discuté
avec lui je demande effectivement à ce
que nous puissions avoir une explication
claire et que sur cette situation qui
est une situation qui est une sitation
explosive au sens propre avec une un
risque de généralisation du conflit à
toute la région avec beaucoup de puissan
qui jouent avec le feu on parle de
l'Iran mais pas seulement et bien ça
suppose qu'effectivement nous ayons une
position qui soit une position établie
claire qui permette d'aller chercher la
paix d'aller chercher la raison d'aller
chercher la responsabilité à un moment
où tant de gens on tout cela il y a une
réunion ce matin de l'intergroupe de
l'anub qu'est-ce que vous allez dire
qu'est-ce que vous allez demander à la
France insoumise mais ce que je viens de
vous dire je demande à ce que nous ayons
une explication pas dans l'heure parce
que ce sera pas ce matin encore a temp
des explications est-ce un moment il
faut pas acter les divergences et dire
on est plus compatible mais attendez on
est en train de dire qu'il va falloir un
jour faire en sorte que les Israéliens
et les Palestiniens se parlent s'il faut
que les Israéliens et les palestinen se
parle ça veut dire que en France il faut
aussi que ne serait-ce que la gauche se
parle et qu'elle avance à un moment en
ayant conscience de sa responsabilité et
conscience de ce que les mots peuvent
créer comme situation derrière et donc
je vous le dis je souhaite effectivement
que toute la gauche avance d'un même pas
et ce pas doit être celui de la raison
et de la responsabilité mais c'est c'est
le cas aujourd'hui Olivier fort le
problème c'est pas c'est pas la c'est
pas la gauche ou c'est c'est même pas la
France insoumise c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est ces positions qui vous
pose problème bah là en l'occurrence je
vais pas je vais pas faire le tri entre
les uns et les autres je vous dis Simp
un peu quand même il y il y a quand même
une difficulté c'est il est plus il est
lui-même isolé ou en but à l'opposition
d'un certain nombre de de de militants
ou de cadres de son propre de son propre
mouvement tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord avec ses positions est-ce qu'à
un moment cette explication que vous
appelez de vos vœux et qui est
nécessaire elle doit pas avoir lieu
directement avec lui mais peut-être il
sera-t-il favor s'il en est d'accord
bien sûr ques doit avoir eu avec lui la
difficulté avec Jean-Luc Mélanchon c'est
que pour l'instant en fait il se
comporte en réalité derrière enfin il
est derrière la direction officielle de
la France insoumise avec laquelle nous
discutons quotidiennement et en même
temps lui intervient par tweet par
message interposés par meeting et donc
euh c'est une vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui mais euh je ne il en a fait
un aut par exemple hier soir de de de de
tweet jean-que Mélenchon il a critiqué
le CRIF à l'origine de la marche à
laquelle vous avez participé je le cite
le CRIF en obligeant tout le monde à
s'aligner sur la position du
gouvernement d'extrême droite israélien
en acceptant de manifester avec le RN en
insultant les él futile du PS le CRIF a
empêché la solidarité des Français avec
la volonté de paix qu'est-ce que vous
dites de ça mais je dis que c'est enfin
quand on a commis une faute politique on
la reconnaît plutôt que de chercher à
chaque étape à discréditer tous les
autres la réalité c'est que hier nous
avons manifesté non pas pour soutenir le
gouvernement deagiaou nous avons
manifesté notre solidarité à l'égard du
peuple israélien victime du terrorisme
de la même façon que j'ai lu un autre
tweet de Jean-Luc Mélenchon où il
explique
que il est dans une enfin que
il qu'il accuse le PS parmi d'autres
partis politiques d'être d'avoir cherché
à affamer Gaza et d'avoir accepté l'idée
que la Commission européenne pourrait
interrompre suspendre ses aides au
territoires occupés la réalité c'est que
c'est fa sal les pays qui s sont opposés
en disantureusement que l'Union européne
n'a pas suivi le PS mais c'est tellement
c'est tellement faux que il cite Borel
qui est socialiste et quels sont les
gouvernements qui il se sont opposés à
cette suspension c'est le gouvernement
espagnol dirigé par qui par un
socialiste et qui en France s'est opposé
à cette suspension des aides les
socialistes donc tout ça n'a absolument
aucun sens et il faudrait quand même
retrouver là aussi je le dis un peu de
responsabilité de raisons quand on a
comm une faute on bien on la reconnaît
et on on ne continue pas enfin tout ne
peut pas ENF je vois bien queà chaque
fois c'est une logique de bloc qui fait
que en fait on avance sans jamais
vouloir reculer avec qui que ce soit
c'est pas possible mais la faute
politique c'est de ne pas avoir dès le
départ reconnu qu'il y avait un acte
terroriste et d'avoir laissé penser que
le Hamas pouvait représenter le peuple
palestinien que c'était des forces
palestiniennes régulières en quelque
sorte et que c'était une un acte de
guerre non ça n'était pas un acte de
guerre c'était un acte terroriste qui
méritait une condamnation claire ferme
et qui ne supposit aucune atténuation
mais on a quand même l'impression qu'il
prend un peu tous les prétextes pour
vous taper dessus pour taper sur le P
est-ce qu'à un moment il faut que vous
tapiez vous aussi du point sur la table
mais c'est pas une question de taper du
point sur la table moi je ne parle pas
je ne suis pas dans une enfin quand j'ai
construit la nupes je l'ai pas
construite pour telle ou telle
organisation estce que ça pasrivé laanup
depu vous l'AVE conruite je l'ai
construite pour toutes celles et ceux
qui aujourd'hui à gauche ont besoin
d'une espérance et de retrouver cette
capacité à demain faire remplacer le
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron et éviter
la catastrophe de l'extrême droite et
donc quand je parle je m'adresse à toute
la gauche je ne suis pas là pour
simplement faire de la politique
politicienne pour essayer de faire voilà
je ne suis pas dans la pologe comme on
dit parfois je suis là simplement pour
essayer de trouver une voie qui permett
d'emener toute la gauche sur une
position qui permette enfin l'alternance
mais comme le dit Stéphan il y a des
divisions à la France insoumise est-ce
qu'à un moment il n'est pas le temps de
remettre à plat l'anupe d'en écarter
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et sa ligne et de
rebâtir avec la partie de la France qui
n'est pas d'accord avec lui écoutez je
pense surtout que là nous sommes en
train de parler d'un sujet qui est
suffisamment grave et suffisamment
sérieux pour ne pas d'un seul coup le
faire tomber à ce niveaulà de la
discussion on n'est pas en train de
parler de la Nupe on est en train de
parler d'un conflit qui un conflit
majeur qui risque de se généraliser et
donc je pense que chaque chose en son
temps et que il n'est pas l'heure de
parler de cela nous avons aujourd'hui un
sujet qui est un sujet extrêmement
sérieux et qui comment comprendrait-on à
travers le monde que aujourd'hui en
France on se pose la question de la de
jeanluc Mélenchon et la nup alors jel
m c'est aussi ce que ça veut dire est-ce
que il y a une forme d'antisémitisme
dans la position de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
quand on voit qu'il y a une
recrudescence des actes antisémites en
France non attendezz pas ENF je vous ai
dit mon désaccord profond avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n'allait pas jusqu'à expliquer
que désormais il ser
responsable dis pas qu'il est
responsable je vous dis just est-ce
qu'il y a une forme est-ce qu'il y a une
forme d'antisémitisme et est-ce que ça
ne peut pas avoir des conséquences sur
ce qui se passe aussi en France suréc
antisétistisétis d'extrme droite etis
antisémitisme qui est né en fait du
conflit israëlo-palestinien en tout cas
qui a trouvé refuge dans ce conflit
israëlo-palestinien pour s'exprimer et
donc ça existe mais dans la position de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a pas une forme
d'antisémitisme pour mais non je ne
pense pas et
franchement n pas on peut avoir des
désaccord avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon on ne
peut pas non plus en faire le diable
absolu c'est pas a un moment où il faut
si la première ministre elle-même dit
que c'est de l'antiséonisme qui confère
à de l'antisémitisme première ministre
non mais la première ministre a choisi
son terrain on sait très bien ce qu'elle
fait et depuis un an on voit bien ce
qu'elle cible et ce qu'elle cherche
aujourd'hui moi ce que je vous dis c'est
que on peut avoir des désaccord avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon sans pour autant
l'accuser de tous les mots c'est aussi
simple que ça et donc là aussi ça
suppose c'est pas parce que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon parfois m'accuse injustement
que moi à mon tour je vais m je vais me
résoudre à cumuler les fake news pour
pour pouvoir discréditer tel ou tel
quand il dit hier qu'il y a une
lapidation médiatique contre la France
insoumise le mot n'est pas choisi au
hasard comment vous réagissez le mot
n'est pas certainement le bon c'est
c'est le mot qui pose problème bah là en
l'occurrence c'est le mot en fait qu' et
la raison pour laquelle en l'occurrence
la France insoumise est attaqué
aujourd'hui c'est parce que tout
simplement ils ont commis cette faute
politique qui du coup a donné un bâton
pour les faire battre et donc c'est
assez logique que ils se le prennent
mais voilà c'est il faut
aussi voilà il faut que chacun retrouve
un peu de voilà j'ai beaucoup utilisé le
mot raison ce auour ce matin je crois
que c'est certainement le mot qui manque
le plus aujourd'hui on a compris que
vous n'actez pas la rupture avec laanup
malgré le fait que certains chez vous
vous le demandent on a entendu Jérôme
Gadge dimanche dire qu'il fallait poser
cette question alors qu'il est il est
pas entinup hein Jérôme Gad mais on a le
droit de poser la question moi je suis
pour qu' se poser toutes les questions
du monde et Jérôme la pose parce que il
il a évidemment en enfin c'est la
sensibilité de tous c'est vrai que quand
on entend quand on lit le communiqué
initial de pH insoumise bah on est
franchement heurté choqué parce que ça
heurte nos convictions profondes donc je
je je ne suis pas étonné que Jérôme ait
répondu à ce moment-là à la question qui
lui était posée en disant que oui il
s'interrogeait et on on a le droit de
s'interroger sur une participation
maintenant ce que je vous dis en
responsabilité c'est que d'abord un
c'est pas le moment de poser cette
question là qu'on a d'abord mieux à
faire c'est de rappeler des positions
chercher à entraîner toute la gauche
cette position là et que je vois que
sous la pression fr insoumise à un
moment a fait un pas de côté et a
commencé à revenir dans le r donc ça
c'est bien et ensuite ensuite que nous
n'utilisons pas chaque séquence pour
faire de la politique politicienne à un
moment où il faut faire de la grande
politique et la grande politique c'est
de dire aujourd'hui ce qui se passe au
ProcheOrient est inquiétant et nous
devons nous uvrer à la pacification
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à la poser en
interne cette question Caro delg
notamment vous demande de réunir les
instances du PS pour discuter de la
position vis-à-vis de la France
insoumise ne croyez pas que en fait il y
ait un seul moment où au PS il a pas de
discussion nous sommes un grand parti
démocratique et chaque semaine au bu
national il y a une discussion et Carole
Delga depuis un an et demi toutes les
semaines elle ne vient pas au B national
mais enfin toutes les semaines ces
représentants nous disent la même chose
donc c'est pas nouveau non plus
simplement admettez aussi que
franchement est-ce qu'on a pas mieux à
faire dans la période qu'enfin est-ce
que enf est-ce qu'on a simplement à dire
la nuupesse la nuupesse la nuupess
est-ce qu'on a pas à s'interroger sur la
politique je lisais ce matin uber
viedrine qui a été ministre de fris
militairant bah il faut aussiber
viedrine comprendre ce qui se passe
expliquer et essayer de voir comment on
évite en fait un drame une explosion
imaginez que nous sommes peut-être à la
à la veille d'un conflit qui se
généralise dans tout le proche orient
est-ce que ça ça ne devrait pas être ça
qui nous mobilise et voilà moi
j'aimerais bien que la politique ne se
limite pas comme
vous avez entendu vous avez entendu on
imagine hier François Hollande qui
félicite la lucidité de ceux qui
remettent en question l'appartenance à
laanup et il dit il faut être exigeant
vis-à-vis de ceux qui la compose sinon
on est dans un suivisme désolant ben
écoutez est-ce que vous trouvez que je
suis dans un suivisme désolant est-ce
que vous trouvez que je suis simplement
là pour adresser des félicitations à
celles et ceux avec qui je suis en
désaccord la réponse évidemment est non
donc je suis ferme sur mes principes et
en même temps je voudrais que chacun
comprenne que dans le moment que nous
vivons il y a mieux à faire que de faire
la politique politicienne parlons des
grands sujets alors le grand sujet c'est
que vous vous redoutez l'embrasement un
conflit qui se
généralise au Proche Orient vous avez
raison il y a ce risque là mais il y a
aussi est-ce qu'il pour vous à votre
sens est-ce qu'il y a le risque que ce
conflit s'importe en France aussi divise
les Français et qu'est-ce que là
qu'est-ce que parce que le proche orient
ça nous concerne tous mais c'est quand
même plus loin que ce qui se passe en
France comment est-ce que vous vous
comptez agir pour apaiser les tensions à
qu'on est en train de voir monter autour
du sujet bien sûr vous avez entièrement
raison mais nous ne sommes ni israéliens
ni palestinien et donc c'est bien que
chacun prenne fait causes pour les uns
et pour les autres la position de la
France la position historique de la
France c'est la position d'une solution
à deux états c'est celle-là qu'il faut
défendre et permettre par cette prise de
position que devrait rappeler la France
et ne pas se limiter à soutenir
aveuglément là aussi le gouvernement de
netanahou c'est de rappeler cette
position parce qu'elle est la seule qui
permette de faire coexister les uns et
les autres et de permettre de rappeler
que la France n'est pas en train de
prendre parti pour les uns ou pour les
autres mais pour dire que il y a
forcément une solution politique doit
être trouvé et que cette solution
politique elle doit conduire à ce que
chaque peuple soit respecté est-ce que
vous considérez aujourd'hui que la
France prend officiellement fait é caus
pour le gouvernement israélien je vois
j'écoute j'entends ce que dit à la fois
la ministre affaires étrangères ce que
dit le président de la République et
malheureusement je les entends tenir
pour l'instant et je pense que ça peut
changer et je ne désespère pas et je
pense que là-dessus il y a une forme de
continuité historique et je me rappelle
que même c'était y compris Nicolas
Sarkozi qui avait parlé de Gaza prison à
ciel ouvert donc ça prouve que il y
avait quand même il y a quand même eu
des positions qui ont été prises dans le
passé Charles de Gaulle François
mitteran qui ont permis de tracer une
voix et cette voie c'est celle euh de de
la France celle d'une nation qui
considère qu'elle est porteuse d'une
solution de paix et non pas simplement
là pour épouser les thèses des uns et
des autres parce que il y a je le crois
vraiment
une nécessité absolue aujourd'hui que de
faire entendre un chemin de raison de
paix et de concorde merci Olivier fort
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin la Une de West France et Gaza
sous les bombes merci Stéphane Vernet
d'avoir été là on passe tout de suite au
club de territoire